You. Hello everyone. It is June
2, 2022 and we're in week five
of textbook group cohort one. We're
having our second discussion on chapter
two and we will
get right to the questions. First, just
wanted to highlight the Math learning
group, especially for those who are not
regularly attending the meetings yet.
The meetings are on 19 UTC on
Wednesdays. But just with everything,
don't let the synchronous time dissuade
you. We can set up other synchronous
times if people want to cowork. And also
the resources and the modifications are
all asynchronous. So we've been doing
several things in the Math learning
group. First, we've been sharing
important resources and categorizing
them. So if somebody wants to look at a
video on something or find a textbook on
something, or if you come across
something useful, just add it here. And
then if you feel like leveraging the
resources that you or other people have
added, then you can categorize it in the
table and just add a few pieces of
information on it. We have a notation
table that we'll be building,
especially as we get into the continuous
time active inference. We have some
questions, less so questions about the
textbook and more so, just cool math
questions that people are raising as
they're discussing the material.
And then we're building a math oriented
overview. So we've gotten up to equation
2.5 in chapter two and this is just
sort of like point by point, like what
are the formalisms doing? Where are the
figures coming into play? How are some
things related? And any and
all note taking can be added. You can
always add it to like unsorted notes or
erota and then we can categorize it
later. But this is how we develop a
shared epistemic resource that's useful
for everyone. And we're going to come to
this in the questions. So we won't go
into detail right now, but equation 2.5
is the variational free energy. 2.6 is
about expected free energy, the G, and
this is a key equation and set of
equations. So yesterday with Blue,
Brock, Jessica Jakub, we went
through and line by line we went with
examples, natural language readings,
questions, interpretations, and then
Yaakob added some derivations. Like how
are those three lines in 2.5 related to
each other? How do we go from the energy
and entropy formulation to the
complexity accuracy formulation?
So this is the essence of understanding
the equations. It's an infinite learning
journey for everyone. So whatever level,
whether you want to. Be.
Catching up to what has been written
here, or whether you see ways to
reorganize it and go beyond and add more
connections, every single background and
level of math familiarity can contribute
in this way. But we'll come to the more
details on 2.5 in the questions.
Any just preliminary thoughts
that people would like to share? They
can raise their hand or write in the
chat at any time. Is there anything that
anybody wants to share before we start
going through the questions, starting
with the most upvoted ones that we
haven't addressed, but we'll just pause
for a few seconds. Tune into the chapter
two regime of attention upvote any
questions that you'd like to see
addressed? Post anything in the chat?
Yes, Jose? Yeah, I'd like to
ask if there's a recording of the math
sessions which you had. No,
we record Stick mergically with the
traces in the notes and we had this
conversation like about whether it
should be recorded or et cetera. If
there's enough desire, we could do
something like have some unrecorded and
some recorded. This session is obviously
recorded and rewatchable here and
we do many live streams and there is a
lot of recorded material. And so we want
to also hold a space for people who
don't want to speak on a recorded
version, even though everything's
recorded in universe and in each other's
minds. But yes, if there's enough
interest in people who want to record
sessions, we absolutely will do it.
We also just wanted to make sure that
there was a total open math learning
space where people wouldn't even have
that cross their horizon. But we did
discuss that yesterday.
Thank you. Yeah. Any other comments?
People can just raise their hand with
six in gather or right in the chat. So
we're going to just go
to the questions and there's still time
to upvote, like during the discussions
and we're just going to upvote the ones
once we've discussed them. So we'll
start with the first question that we
haven't discussed yet.
Okay, this is from page 32.
Policy dependent outcomes are not
immediately available, but they can be
predicted by chaining together two
components of the generative model. The
first is our beliefs about how hidden
states change their time.
Just want to find what the second part
was.
The second component is the likelihood
distribution.
What really changes as a result of
policy selection, the hidden states or
the outcomes? Bringing a jacket
doesn't necessarily change the
temperature hidden state but instead
changes my observation perception of
whether it's cold or not. Can we
actually change hidden states with
policy selection? And what would be an
example of this?
Does anyone want to raise their hand and
give a thought on this question?
What really changes as a result of
policy selection? The hidden states are
the outcomes while
people are raising their hand. I'll give
one possible thought. The answer is both
slash. It depends. So bringing a jacket
does change the temperature around you.
It's not just changing your perception
of temperature. So one example of
changing a hidden state with
temperature, hidden state of temperature
with policy selection would be like
changing the setting on the thermostat
that is intervening into the causal
process, the generative process that's
giving rise to temperature, which is
giving rise to your perceptions of
temperature. And so assuming that your
temperature perception is accurate, you
are able to change both the temperature
in the room or the temperature around
you with the jacket. And thus because
temperatures are giving rise to
observations of temperature, also you
end up changing both blue.
So this is my question and I think Karl
kind of possibly started to answer it on
the live stream yesterday. I need to
think about it more and unpack it a
little bit more. But we change
the temperature around ourselves, but
we're not going to change the
thermometer reading by bringing a
jacket. Right,
but anyway, what Karl said and what
might be beneficial for others to hear
is that when you think about what's
changing, it's like really, when you
think about a hidden state, there's a
causal chain underlying that hidden
state. And the same thing, like when you
think about an observation, there's a
causal chain underlying that
observation. So like, no, I'm not going
to change what my eyes tell me the
temperature is, but I'm going to change
what my body tells me the temperature
is. And so it depends because it's a
multisensory observation,
right? So which sense is going to change
not my visual reading on the
thermometer, but my physical perception
of cold. Also yesterday on the live
stream, thomas Parr and Karl Friston
joined So that was really awesome and a
great one to watch. 45.1 and we can
continue on this Ali and then Mike.
Yeah, I think that's what meant by the
word hidden in the statement because if
it was transparency observation
to any kind of perception or
observation, I don't think it would be
called a hidden state. I believe that
the reason it's called this, it's called
as such is because it's opaque to any
kind of perception or observation. So
it's kind of inherent to the universe
and probably not
amenable to any change
or action. Thanks Mike.
Yeah, I'm not sure if I'm thinking about
it the right way, but intuitively. I was
thinking that policy selection would
update the expected conditions or the
expected state, so maybe adjusting
the priors in evasion sense.
Thanks. So we'll come to this later,
but the answer based upon the partially
observable Markov decision process,
discrete and continuous time versions,
policies pi intervene in between hidden
states and how they change their time.
Different hidden states, should they be
giving rise to different observations,
will result in different observations.
So changing the thermometer policy
selection is intervening in the causal
process of temperature changing through
time in the room hidden state. And if
the temperature in the room is
associated through the a matrix with
your observations of temperature, then
you will be changing your observations.
And then just like Mike said, that is
reflected based upon the expectations
that the individual has about the
observations of temperature. So they're
both changing because the hidden states
and the observations are linked. That's
what it means to have a generative model
or for there to be a partially
observable model with hidden states and
observables hierarchical models. A given
state could be in emission from a higher
state and emitting a lower state. And
that's kind of like how the current
moment is like a consequence of the
past, but it's a cause of the future.
So this is related to Bayesian modeling,
but using this architecture, we can say
that policy intervenes only in between
hidden states. We don't directly
intervene in how observations appear.
Any other thoughts or questions on this
question?
Okay.
All right.
In Figure 2.2 figure
2.2 they
write x, Star, and X. So that's going
to be generative process and generative
model. Latent variables. Hidden states
do not necessarily live in the same
space of measurement. It might be the
case that hidden states in the external
world take on values that lie outside
the space of explanations available to
the brain. Conversely, it might be that
the brain's explanations include
variables that do not exist in the
outside world. For example, the former
could be five dimensional and the latter
two dimensional. Or one could be
continuous and the other could be
categorical. So what are examples
people can think of where the
dimensionality of the generative
model, the cognitive entity, is the same
as the generative process, the niche
process giving rise to observations,
passing them to the generative model.
That's one question.
Second question how does this approach
or framing speak up to
the map territory debate hashtag,
instrumentalism and realism?
What papers or live streams best
characterize how active inference models
the action, cognition perception loop?
And what other possibilities or models
are there for the action, cognition
perception loop? What would be the
different strengths and limitations of
these different framings and
partitionings? Thanks, Joe. And then
Blue and then anyone else who raises
their hand. I was just
thinking a nice case where you could say
dimensionality is pretty obvious is
board games. If I was trying to
anticipate what my opponent is going to
play in a board game,
they have a limited number of possible
moves and I'm assuming I'm playing the
same game, I'm expecting them to make
some move on the same board. So me,
that sounds like the dimensionality is
the same because you're in this limited
world, I don't have to know what they're
thinking. I don't have to know what they
had for breakfast. I don't have to know
a lot of stuff. I'm just thinking, and I
might be wrong. What movement?
Great. Thanks for that.
So with the same dimensionality, it's
like if we're playing the same game,
then we're playing a game where we're
tracking a little cursor on the screen.
The movement space within that is just
the x and the y value or just two
dimensions. And so the
observation is like the location in two
dimensions, and then that is
the same dimensionality that inference
is occurring on. But as an I'm thinking
just to add a little bit to more of my
comment, if I wanted to enrich it and
say oh, but I'm starting to think
strategically and anticipating their
next move or anticipating maybe they're
bluffing or maybe I'm bluffing and I
want to see if they know that I'm
bluffing. We add more dimensionality.
And I guess in principle, again, you
could still add that dimensionality in
somehow in parity with parts of the
hidden states. You see what I mean?
That I'm thinking, oh, they think they
know I'm bluffing or I think they're
bluffing. You're talking again about the
same thing. You don't have to know what
they had for breakfast. You're just
talking about this extra information
which isn't in the board itself, but
that gets a bit more complicated. Yes,
thanks. So that
is a good answer. Other ones that people
have written thermostat is having
the same dimensionality, like it's a
temperature value, it's a dimensionality
of one. And so then the person's
generative model is also on this
one dimensional temperature axis. And
then they mentioned that it could be
like categorical versus continuous.
So without going too many rabbit holes
deep, we could just say temperature in
the room is a continuous variable. It's
like taking on a number. It could be a
decimal point number between any number,
zero to infinity.
The person's model might be the same
dimensionality like one. But then they
might be trying to make a categorical
estimate. Is this livable or unlivable?
Is it hot, neutral or cold? That'd be
like a three state categorical model.
So the generative process doesn't have
to have the same dimensionality or
continuous versus discreteness of
the generative model.
Second answer for same dimensionality.
Controls for a car have two degrees
physical degrees of freedom the
acceleration, the speed, whether you can
hit the gas or the brake and the
direction of the front wheels controlled
by the steering wheel. So there's
like a speed dimension and then there's
a turning angle dimension. This is the
model that people use when controlling a
car at some level about abstraction.
And then the acceleration dimension can
be acted upon through policy
selections like stepping on the gas and
the brakes. And then it's like, well,
those are two categorically different
affordances and then there's continuous
variables inside of that categorical
difference. And we'll talk about like
hybrid control models with both
categorical and continuous aspects in
play. And in this case, the speed
of the car in the speed axis is the
hidden state. The observable would be
the speedometer. So again,
the gas and the brake are policy
selections that modify. Let's say we're
thinking about a train. No turning
policy selection is influencing
how speed changes through time. And if
you have a speedometer that's accurate,
even if it's noisy, it's giving rise to
observations reflecting those changes in
speed. But gas and brake do not change
the speedometer directly. They're
changing a hidden cause, which is the
speed different dimensionality
rain comes from clouds. Simple mental
model is that the darker the clouds,
the more there will be. That's a two
dimensional generative model.
So how much rain,
how dark the clouds? And this
also is going to speak to this map
territory. Someone could say, well,
there's the size of the cloud and
there's also the humidity. So that's
like maps with increasing amounts of
variables. So no one's denying the
territory of the actual chaos of the
cloud. It's just a question of how much
detail and what data we're actually
treating as observables. And what
sophistication is being taken with
unobserved variables with hidden states
which are modeled in the computer or on
paper, but they're not directly
observed, then the mental model can be
decomposed even more and then add
infinitem. On the reality side, the
actual generative process
for weather is including
all the butterflies. So that's a
cognitive model that is two dimensional.
In this case, how much rain is expected
and how dark is the cloud, that one
could make increasingly nuanced
cognitive models. But whatever cognitive
model is being proposed, the generative
process is something that's like totally
different. Cognitive model generative.
Model map generative process niche
territory. Plants do better when they
have water and fertilizer. Generative
mental Model leaf droopiness is a sign
of moisture, but leaf size and color are
signs for nutrients. So one could
imagine like a causal graph where
there's like moisture level is
unobserved, but it is emitting leaf
droopiness as a state. But we're
observing leaf droopiness and we're
using that to infer moisture, whereas
nutrient is an unobserved state to the
visual gardener. And then they're using
two dimensions, leaf size and color. So
this is a three dimensional cognitive
model leaf droopiness, leaf size and
color are observables. And then there's
two unobserved cognitive states,
nutrients and moisture.
But whatever map gets constructed,
that's not the plant. Now, the gardener
might then want to take an informative
experiment being an optimal Bayesian
gardener, and then measure something,
take something that was an unobserved in
the initial model and then measure using
LiDAR, like using some sort of sensor to
understand. And then that would make
that data point an outcome related
through some a matrix, which we're going
to get to later of the hidden state
being like the true levels of copper.
And then if we have an accurate test,
we can start using the outcomes of the
observed levels of copper and start
flushing out our model that way. Joe.
I chucked in a comment below. I hope
it's showing up just that. The other
part of the question was asking about
the map territory debate.
And here's from the person who kind of
came up with that dichotomy in the way
we usually talk about it. He says that
the map and territory should have a
similar structure. And I think that's
really interesting to think about. If
I'm making again moves in a board game,
I might make a reduction of their
mental state. Maybe I'm playing against
a computer for example. So I don't know
that they have a mental state or maybe
I'm playing against a person I
happen to know as a beginner. So I know
they're likely to make naive mistakes or
whatever, something like that. But I was
just thinking like with regard to the
leaf droopiness thing, you could have
all kinds of really badly structured
models of plant health.
Maybe it relates to how recently you
watered it or something. Well, that
sounds good in general, but if it's a
cactus, maybe that's like a defeater to
your system. So the point being it
seemed interesting that your map should
maybe if it doesn't have exactly the
same dimensionality, should still be a
nice reduction of the thing you're
trying to model, whatever that means.
Thanks. One aspect
on this is evolution, natural selection,
dissipation in our world, sweeping off
the table entities that are failing to
at least be adequate. So in a
dissipative situation that we're in,
the map has to be at least good enough,
otherwise the entity will fail to exist.
So that sort of closes the loop and is
like we're seeing the persistent
entities that are acting good enough to
navigate. And it's just interesting like
how many the allegory of the cave
to the blind people and the elephant and
realism instrumentalism and we've had
many live streams on
this especially. Check out number 14 on
Mel Andrew's paper. The math is not the
territory. So this one sort of
explicitly jumps in right there and
tackles this issue with the FEP front
and center. So this is a great series of
live streams. The dot zeros are
background and context where we just go
over the paper in a small group, like
one person or two or three people and
then the dot one and the dot two. We
usually have more of an open
participatory discussion and the authors
sometimes to usually join. So
everybody's welcome to participate in
contributing to dot zeros as well as
enjoying the dot one and the dot two.
But just so you know, when you're
looking in the live stream table, the
dot zero is a good one to watch first
because it has the background and
overview on the paper. But then like
yesterday in 45.1,
we had Friston and Par join to discuss
just so that people can navigate the
live streams a little better. So we can
continue asynchronously adding more
thoughts on like map territory and what
papers and live streams and what other
possibilities for the action perception
loop. But these are big fun areas.
But we're going to continue with the
questions on
the notion of surprise.
Is the agent's perception not only
affected by the influence of not only
its environment but also an agent's
peers? So perhaps to restate, how is an
agent's perception affected by its
direct perception and its assessment of
peers? So the agent's peers are updating
their beliefs in a collaborative
fashion. What would be the extent
of the update to an agent's generative
model of perception if the agent
witnesses the annihilation of one of its
peers. For example, something like this,
okay, will to be from bird box. Not
going to open any video links, but
perhaps we'll observe some annihilation
like some animal attacks one of the wild
beast on the right, but then the other
one learns. So this is a great
video. Definitely good to watch.
So far in the textbook and indeed for
the textbook it's focusing on just like
we saw in figure two two, it's like one
entity in the niche.
The niche can consist of others like me.
Other entities that I expect are similar
to myself in terms of like the coarse
grained cognitive architecture they have
or their preferences, their affordances.
They're able to do similar things, they
want similar things. They have a similar
history to some extent.
So that is sometimes called
thinking through other minds. Ttom and
just to give one thought and then anyone
can raise their hand. If we were to
accurately observe another
peer taking some action and then failing
to exist, we're driving on the highway,
and then we observe somebody taking a
policy to go off the highway, and then
we see them fail to exist, we could use
that information to update our
beliefs about the consequences of the
action to drive off the highway.
So I believe it would be possible
to implement every variation of direct
perception, direct perception of peers
thinking through other minds, theory of
mind learning by example,
imitation, contrarianism.
Every phenomena could be modeled as just
has to be whatever the specific model
is actually about. Ali.
I have a related question about 2.5 and
2.6. Well, correct me if I'm
wrong, but I understand that these
equations describe
the behavior of a kind of rational
behavior or the kind of behavior of a
rational agent. Where does irrationality
comes into this? Or let
me put it this way can
irrationality be a parameter?
In order to qualify these two equations,
2.5 and 2.6, or seen
from the other side, can we use
these two equations to measure the
extent of rationality as a measurement
of rationality? Good question.
Here's one quote. And we'll come to
equation 2.5 and six as well because
those are important.
Distinguishing the generative model and
the generative process is really
important. That's the difference between
the entity and the niche. It's important
to distinguish them to contextualize
psychological claims about the
optimality of inference. To the extent
these claims are valid on a Bayesian
view is always contingent on the
organism's resource. So don't
want to step out too far. But
rationality and irrationality. It's
rational to believe in X. It is
irrational to believe in X is always
subjective. From that speaker's
perspective, given the priors and the
update rules, all there is is
rationality. Which is to say this is
just the Bayesian updating process. So
there are maladaptive priors ones that
trend towards dissolution of the entity.
But there aren't irrational priors.
There just is what it is and how it
updates. And then that could be
inadequate, it could be any
number of other things and these are
like getting into relatively complex
cognitive phenomena where there could be
like multiple layered models.
But I would say rationality
in the Bayes process is like the
cognition is Bayes optimal or modeled
with a Bayesian process. And then
sometimes the interaction of the
generative model and the generative
process as appropriately defined
specifically is going to result in what
it results in.
But we will come to 2.5 and 2.6.
Okay here. Suffice to say, yes, social
learning and collective behavior and
emergent outcomes at the group level is
something that's important. But we
haven't addressed it so far in the
textbook, and multi agent models are not
really addressed in the textbook that
much because there's so much to
understand about the kernel of the
perception cognition action loop that
even though it's so important for real
systems, it's not brought up.
Okay, wanting to go to the equation,
the dark room problem for many years,
many Papes firing back and forth.
But let's go to the equations for our
let me check the chat here. Yes,
variational free energy is minimized
through two different possible
approaches minimizing divergence of
Q and P, changing mind and maximizing
evidence, taking action, changing
perception. This is done based upon
prior and present information.
Equation 2.5 variational free energy to
plan best actions, generative models and
internal policies produce simulated
outcomes that can be used to estimate
expected free energy as the average of
the log probability of outcomes.
Equation 2.6 expected free energy
and there's other variants in the
context of planning, planning as
inference. Equation 2.6 provides a view
of EFE that establishes consistency in
measurement units of exploration,
exploitation. The relative balance
between these terms determines whether
behavior is predominantly explorative or
exploitative. 34 in
other words, dissolving the classic
explore exploit dilemma in behavioral
psychology. What causes
this balance to change? I e. What
controls this balance? Very important
and interesting question.
Perhaps we can come to equation 2.5
first and then we can come to equation
2.6. So where
we're going is the future. The future
has several sources of, in principle and
in practice uncertainty. Observations in
the future have not happened. Actions in
the future have not happened and the
causes of future outcomes and
hidden states actions as well as the
generative processes endogenous changes
haven't occurred. So there are several
fundamental and in practice limitations
of the kind of precision that you can
get on the future. That's planning
as inference, it's prospective in
contrast and that's expected free
energy because it's about the free
energy of an expected future.
Variational free energy f expected
free energy is g variational
free energy F is in equation 2.5.
Variational free energy as the question
says, is based upon present and prior
information. So variational free energy
is like now casting and
verging into something kind of like
memory as inference. We're integrating
the past in the sense of our priors
and the present incoming data point why?
And it's like a snapshot evaluation of
optimal perception in the purely sensory
case. And if we include action within
variational free energy, it's taking one
step optimal actions. But those are not
necessarily like the ones that's not
planning. That's just like snapshot
decision making. In contrast, 2.6 will
explicitly consider policies.
It is a function of policy pi and so
it is including planning as inference.
But first let's look at 2.5.
Yaakov or anyone else. Would you like to
just describe one pass?
What is equation 2.5 showing?
I guess if you mean like describing,
say, the first line or the lines in a
bit more detail, essentially the
energy term is just the expectation of
the log of the joint probability of the
data and the observation. So I
don't understand quite why they changed
the notation from appendix B, but Y
would essentially be the S, I think,
and X would be the O.
Yes, anyone could be taking more notes
on this, but Y is the observable data
and X is the hidden state in the POMDP
that we're going to be getting to later
x out there, the hidden state is S and
O are observations. So this is using
more of a regression familiar framework
and variable notation. But this could
also be written LNP of O comma
S observations and states that's the
joint distribution. Joint distribution
with a comma conditional distributions
with a vertical pipe.
Yeah. And so we are also taking the
entropy term is only based on the
beliefs of our hidden states. So people
were saying before that the hidden
states are unobservable. The only thing
that we can say about the hidden states
are the beliefs about the hidden states.
I don't think that the hidden states X
can ever really appear on their own
because we always need to have some kind
of belief about them. And this was also
related to a discussion we were having
yesterday that's interesting that
they kind of switched between the
notation of entropy with H
as the functional and just the
pure expectation with the E,
because the actual definition of entropy
is the expectation of the negative log
of whatever is in is
the variable, which in this case is Q of
X. And that's actually how we get to
the other two expressions with
complexity and accuracy and divergence
and evidence. And there's also a link I
think might be wrong with to
theoretical physics where
free energy is essentially the kind of
cognitive statistical equivalent of the
Lagrangian, which is defined
as kinetic energy minus potential
energy. So we were discussing yesterday
what that means in terms of the energy
and entropy in this case, whether the
energy is perhaps kind of the immediate
cognitive kinetic energy and then the
entropy is like. The potential energy or
vice versa might be
going off on a tangent at this point.
Awesome. Let me just add in a few other
notes. The variables f
is a function. It's the variational free
energy function. The arguments that it
is taking in are Q. That's the
variational distribution that we
control. That's what makes it a
variational free energy. Q is the one
that we control. P is the actual
probability distribution out there. Y is
the data point. So we have on the left
side of the equation, variational free
energy is a function of Q and Y. On the
right side, we have three equal signs
and these are three values, three ways
to phrase this one function. In the
bottom here, Yaakov has shown how this
energy minus entropy can result.
In the second line, complexity minus
accuracy, and in the third line,
divergence minus evidence. So that was
like one really interesting thing, is
it's not like this is how it is and this
is a transformation and then this is the
transformation. Even though in a sense
that was also true, it is also probably
helpful to think about this energy minus
entropy formalism for what it is, which
is the closest to a physics framing of
free energy. And then think about these
two more statistical ontology
ways of framing it, complexity minus
accuracy, which is like very commonly
brought up in the context of model
fitting and divergence minus evidence
also. And yeah,
great. So Blue, if that sounds like a
very helpful norm in the description,
we'll try to have like a description of
the equation. The first row says this,
this people can type it however they
want. And then of course, we can replace
terms that are in the ontology with
the special at sign. And that will
facilitate finding equations that
mention those terms and it will
facilitate translating these equations
and also the descriptions into different
languages, computer languages and human
languages. So then we can work on it in
this ontological space and then make
sure that it's accessible to different
languages. For example, then we
thought about this example of like a
ball and its location in a bowl.
So there's a true location of where it
is in the bowl X. And then there's an
observation of where we're observing the
ball to be. And this also speaks
to the quantum to classical handoff. If
the bowl is a swimming pool and the ball
is a bowling ball, after enough time,
it's going to be at the bottom and not
moving. If the bowl
is like a molecular well and
the ball is like an electron or like one
atom, then repeated measurement is going
to be entirely different. And as the
ball in the bowl become more massive,
it approaches like a classical limit.
Little hints at the continuity between
classical statistical and quantum and
thermophysics. But we thought about this
ball being in the bowl. So we
looked at two different cases, which is
when the ball is being observed in the
bottom of the bowl, it's like,
given the generative model of the shape
of the bowl and gravity,
which is like a potential energy
function, observing the ball at the
center of the bowl is, like, strictly
the most likely thing that could have
happened. And then observing it up on a
side is like a less likely observation.
Eric and then blue.
Yeah. So you mentioned that F is
a function. And as they put it, it's a
function of a function, which is a
functional. So the way I think about
this is that the function that it's a
function of is the Q. So the Q is a
distribution over your beliefs. So I
think of that as being a function that
you're trying to optimize. You're trying
to say, well, how do I adjust my
internal belief state the Q.
And that's what I'm optimizing in this
equation. And the functional says that's
what I'm trying to optimize is that
function and distribution. And then it
breaks down into the two parts, which is
your generative Model P, which says
well, P says for any there's
the joint probability of X. X is
the internal state variable
that you have a distribution over that's
Q. And so how do your Observables and
your internal states go together? And
then you have the entropy term, which is
well, you want to have maximum
uncertainty so that if you're not
constrained by your observations, you
want to be as agnostic as possible about
what the possible values are of your
internal states or make that queue as
flat as possible. As flat as possible
under the constraints of the
observations going through your
generative Model P. So I guess that's
the way I talk through this first line.
Awesome. Thank you, eric blue and then
Brock. So, Eric, that was super helpful.
I've been since yesterday trying to
figure out what exactly is meant by Q.
Here. I get later on we're going to talk
about Q as representing beliefs. But as
it's given, as it's laid out in chapter
two, they don't actually define Q at
all. So I
am having a hard time up here. They
describe it right before they get
into that box. They describe Q in
Section 2.6 as an approximate posterior.
So approximate posterior of what? And
should we denote Q as the function of
beliefs here? Even though it's
like they're skipping ahead and looping
back at the same time? It seems like,
or feels like to. Me,
q is the variational distribution where
the form of the posterior has been
chosen. So exact bays using
matrix multiplication, basically, or
sampling based approaches to approximate
Bayesian computation, like Monte Carlo,
Markov chain, those try to recapitulate
the actual form of P.
So if P is truly bimodal, then exact
Bayes or sampling based approaches would
try to reconstruct that distribution.
In contrast, the variational approach
gains tractability because you're
choosing a posterior, approximate
posterior, a Q of a form that you know
is going to have a tractable
optimization scheme and there's message
passing algorithms that can do it
computationally. So if you choose Q to
be a gaussian, then depending on how you
parameterize it, it's either going to be
seeking the mode and go to the hump
that's bigger and center around that
with a variance, or it'll just spread
out a lot and go over and try to cover
as much probability density as it can by
covering both humps. Okay, so the
variation of free energy function F as a
function of the function representing
the approximate posterior Q and the data
Y is equal to the negative expectation
of Q given the observations x times the
natural log of the probability of the
joint distribution of the data and
observations. Is that the English
translation of that equation? I think I
got it finally, after. Like two days
minus close, I would. Say one
thing I would say slightly different.
It's the expectation over Q,
not expectation of Q.
We actually talked about that a little
bit. Like here we had negative
expectation over Q and yes.
Okay, blue then. Brock yeah, sorry,
the ontology terms don't match the terms
that are given in the book. And I put in
a request in the questions here. If we
can append the ontology because they use
data is the same as observations.
Those are different words, but they're
similar. Yeah, there's a lot
of synonyms or synonymous use, and so
I would hate to step on them. But also
the terms aren't in the ontology at
all. So maybe we should update the
ontology to reflect the terms. We will
absolutely add terms into the
supplemental or eventually into the core
terms if that's required. But just leave
a comment or email activeinference at
gmail to add terms to the ontology if
there's a term that you want to tag
that's not being tagged. Frock.
I feel like you may have indirectly
answered this just now, but in
the math discussion yesterday, we were
talking about specifically about the Q,
the distribution of beliefs over there.
If X is this uncertainty term,
this hidden
state, like, what what
value could it possibly have? Where is
it coming from? Or is that so
Q? Is this property of distribution of
beliefs? Is X the belief value and
that's being generated in
the previous step?
I think we in the Bowl Marble
thing. Like my question was,
or I was just pointing out, I guess that
the hidden state is changing however it
wants, perhaps below our threshold of
observation. That's not
reflected in the equation for obvious
reasons, but then maybe it crosses a
threshold and then we update or
whatever. But where is that X coming
from if it's a hidden state? Do you see
what I'm saying? Is kind of an
ontological problem there. I'm trying to
solve it's like it's a hidden state.
How can have a value or be a variable if
it's hidden? Yes,
Eric, I'll take a stab at
that. So, as shown in the pictures,
there's two hidden states. There's a
hidden state of the real world, and then
there's a hidden state of your
generative model. And the generative
model is whatever the model is. And
that's however the model was built. So
once you have the parameters X, then
that's what you're working with until
you change your model. That was my
yes. And over evolutionary or
developmental times, you get swept off
the table if there isn't adequacy, at
least. But in a simulation environment,
you could make the X and the X star to
be anything but. The hidden state is
as modeled by the generative model of
the cognitive entity. So in
the cognitive model of the entity, in
the bowl example, they're modeling an
unobservable, which is the location of
the ball, and they're modeling an
observable, which is the observation of
location. So both of those are in the
generative model. And then the
generative process would be like there's
somebody with a magnet who's moving the
ball around or something, or it could be
anything. We're going to have
five more minutes before we close this
session. So what does
anyone see in 2.4? What is free
energy minimization doing? And what
does it mean that variational free
energy is an upper bound on the negative
log evidence,
just one quick qualitative read is that
this is what we would actually like to
be minimizing. This is the floor we
truly want to reach would be unsurprised
about observations.
However, that is intractable because
we don't have access to the form or the
parameterization of the true generative
process. What is attractable
approximation? Approximate Bayesian
computation is variational Bayesian
inference. So here's f q of y q
and y and then this is a KL divergence.
One vertical pipe means conditioned on
like X conditioned on Y x given Y.
Here probability of a hidden state being
the case given a data or the other
flipping, which would be the probability
of given data point given a hidden
state. Two vertical lines is in
divergence notation. And that's the
divergence between this and that between
Q of X and between P of X given Y.
So that reducing this divergence,
which has very nice properties in terms
of its implementation, is bringing us
to lower our upper bound on what we
really want to be minimizing in a
tractable way. So that's one aspect on
free energy minimization. And then here
is reframing the two ways that free
energy, variational free energy can be
minimized through perception, the
updating of beliefs. And we'll talk more
about the continuity between perception
and learning. Like if one observes the
ball moving across the visual field, is
that perception or is it parameter
learning updating the location of the
ball? That depends on the timescale and
such or action can be taken so that the
expected observations are changed to
maximize evidence. And then in
the last minutes, Ali asked,
can a hidden state be an unquantifiable
quality, like a
qualia quality or like an unquantifiable
quantity?
Well, of course most qualities can be
parameterized, but well,
perhaps we can think of a hidden state
as a pure quality that
cannot be fundamentally
unquantifiable and we cannot
parameterize it. I mean, can we think of
such a hidden state?
Brock, I was just going to say probably
the quantifiable way to state that
question is are there intractable
hidden states? Which the answer to that
is like, obviously yes. Can we get
some estimate on it? Yes. But then is
that commensurate with the idea? And
then does that mean it's a quality and
not a quantity? I don't know. And also
to the earlier discussion about the
dimensionality of the generative model
and the generative process. The
unquantifiable part could be like the
baby's happiness, but then we're able to
still have an inference on the happiness
as a parameter x, the underlying state
that's giving rise to the different
sounds without necessarily
knowing the distributional form of
happiness. But we have to have a
distributional form for the variational
approximation of happiness. Joe, I was
just going to say, I think that this
qualitative versus quantitative
distinction is interesting. If you're
thinking about like a light source,
it's a source of electrons. Well, you
could count the number of electrons,
but whether or not there is a light
source, there a source of electrons in
this framework I'm proposing, you're not
counting that, you're just saying there
is a light source or some other
dimensions. That's the thing we've been
calling dimensions. Yes, you can count
the number of dimensions, but given that
they're all different, they're not
really relatable to each other. Thanks.
Yes, very interesting. So in our final
seconds, we'll just point towards 2.6,
which is expected free energy g
and its prospective, which is going to
enable inference conditioned on action
x hidden states, the world conditioned
on policy selection. And that is what is
going to allow comparison of different
policies, which are sequences of actions
over a given time horizon. So minimizing
the divergence between two things minus
some things, reframing it as a few
things. So we didn't go as much into 2.6
as we did into 2.5 because 2.5 is an
important precursor and simpler cousin
of 2.6, but it's like super important
and especially to those who are here and
those who are not here. We would really
love over multiple cohorts when
everybody will hopefully be able to join
and rejoin as participant, as
facilitator, to be able to annotate all
the equations with what they mean,
because what is there to be said about
expected free energy without some
understanding of what this is actually
discussing? What variables go in, what
is it doing, how are some of them being
related? So we want to learn this
and we can do it collaboratively. If
people just pick and choose affordances,
they see annotate some things and then
they can highlight it and say I'm not
sure about this, but I just wanted to
add it. Can somebody improve it? And so
on. Like we're all there to help each
other learn and improve our epistemic.
Niche 2.6 is expected. Free energy.
There's further discussion on Expected
free energy, showing how it's composed
of these five sections, and that by
leaving some out you get different
special cases that are quite important.
For example, leaving out this, you get
this leaving out just one, you get 2345
and so on. Figure two six. And then
there's a summary of the low road to
active inference. That's chapter two.
So this concludes chapter two and
our discussion in cohort one. In the
coming two weeks we're going to be
discussing chapter three, the High Road
to Active Inference. It's going to take
another tack and we will go through it
in the coming two weeks and be
addressing people's questions. But
hopefully we can continue answering and
addressing just wherever we see fit. No
one's going to do it all, but we do need
everybody to do some hopefully.
We're going to now close recording.
We'll then take a 1 minute break and
then in this room we're going to
continue with Dot tools. If you want to
continue discussing the textbook or
anything else, then head up to a room up
and to the left. But in this room in 1
minute we're going to continue with Dot
tools. So thanks everybody. See you